today we celebrate the inauguration of
labor rights week it takes
place from august 30 to september 3 it
is a concentrated effort of all the
mexico consulates in the usa that this
week we are dedicated only to
labor rights issues to make sure
that workers  and the workers
know that everyone has rights
regardless of their immigration status. What would
I say to those Mexicans who suffer
some type of labor abuse that they have
confidence? They should go to the consulate to
report
it.  complain
if you are being abused at work it
happens a lot and few cases we know
so we are truly here to
serve you no matter if you have papers or
not everyone has rights
and everyone has the opportunity to come
to the consulate without an appointment to report a
problem he
mentioned apart from the complaints also
that there are rights for workers
who go through cover could they give us a
definition  Initially, the companies, depending
on the type of industry that it is, have to
take various sanitary measures to
contain cob and so if one, for
example, works in the
meat packing industry, they must have
adequate sanitary measures so that
people do not get infected in the
food management and working shoulder to
shoulder the same in construction in the
hotel industry we know that in las vegas there is a
lot of leadership and awareness that
workers should be taken care of
but there are also bad actors
everywhere so we want the
companies employers employers know
that they also have obligations
to workers many
Latinos are unaware of their labor rights
which do you think would be one
of the most important to highlight in the
Latino community one of the main
problems is the payment of hours  extras
many of us in our countries
were used to working
very hard  without knowing that they had to
pay us for that extra work and then
that is replicated in the US it is replicated in
that working people work extra and are
not paid that is a very
frequent problem here in the US Another
frequent problem is that they do not receive the material
and  the safety equipment necessary to
carry out your work, I mean in
particular in construction and
gardening, so these are the
issues that we have to be very
aware of so that people are safe
in their workplace,
how important is it?  having signed
this so that people understand what it
consists of and what it means
today we are signing a memorandum of
understanding with it, which is the
occupational safety and health
administration, which is about disseminating
information on safety and
health at work but also to
detect  cases it is useless for us to
hand out brochures and speak at
a press conference without
people finding out and coming to report the cases
like this and  I know that together the federal government of the United
States and the government of Mexico are joining
efforts so that health and
safety at work prevail.
salary
that is owed and I am also going to sign another
memorandum of understanding with the
labor commissioner of nevada so
that the state laws in nevada are
observed and complied with for the
immigrant community in particular
because how
people start to also be part of
social networks  We are disseminating
all the activities that we are going to have
here at the consulate. We are going to have tables
with information from the different
agencies of the US government and also
from non-profit organizations that
support migrants. We are going to have
nine online seminars that are going  let's
see the consulate's facebook live and
we're going to have call banks we're going to
broadcast a phone number with a
particular topic for  For people to call and we
answer their questions,
something else that wants snow,
don't really be afraid to go
to the Mexican consulate, it doesn't matter if they
are Mexican or not,
we really want to serve the entire
Hispanic community in Las Vegas and Nevada